uh that performance got uh a lot of
folks attention uh
[Music]
LeBron Kevin Garnett weighing
in Draymond Draymond he's allowed to do
that yeah he can still I thought he was
in social
media back Ty job being back is good for
Hoops um agreed I mean it was great to
see him back on the floor and great to
see him doing what he does
but to have it come down the way it did
Shaq that was unbelievable that's how
you come back a hell of a comeback story
probably one of the best comeback
stories I've seen young fellow made a
mistake he did did his time he paid his
dues he didn't complain he took it like
Ernie like we say in the streets he took
like a real G he came back but he came
back with that look Ernie I was I was
concerned you know he had seven points
in the first half but like you said he's
a dog and AR dogs do not stop and we
don't quit and you know a guy like J my
R you just got to give your guys a
chance gave his guys a chance and what
they do the last 10 seconds they put it
in his hand and this guy wants to be
great I respect guys like this they want
to be great J I'm happy for you I'm
happy for you and your family you get
the golf clap for me that's how you come
back Young Brother well you know
everyone says it's great from the back
he's one of the top 10 players in the
NBA you know his ability to score the
ball to make a
difference not
I I do remember I I'm I'm I do remember
there were a group of people screaming
when jar would get hurt last year oh the
Memphis Grizzlies a better team without
job couple years ago they had a a good
record when when oh look how they still
play well is is he really no the
difference is his ability
to bring the attention to him which
allows you to play Freer and and then
even when he's not there that freedom
carries over when he's when he's not
there and so you're able to continue it
knowing that he's coming back but when
you're one of the top 10 players in the
league your effect on the game is more
than just points yeah he had 34 points
but he had there's e easy lobs for for
uh the interior players they're spacing
as as Desmond Bane said oh they can't
they you're not going to you're going to
come off of me for J okay I'm I'm going
hit you in the head with a three oh you
don't you're going to leave Jones on the
island and play one-on-one with J he's
going to score the basketball and win
the game so now there's real decisions
to be made in the NBA when you play the
Memphis Grizzlies there's no oh we could
just guard them and they can't win
they're not talented enough now they're
back to having that edge I just think
it's I just think it's a huge win Shack
when you when you bring a guy back when
you're six and 19 and you're looking at
this uphill battle you got a you got
seven and a half games to make up to get
in the 10 spot and you start the game
the way you do and you're down a bundle
you fall down by 24 in this game and
it's like oh I don't know I just think
that's a huge confidence Builder uh and
a great step forward for this team you
know when J was doing an interview you
saw the guys that had energy I I haven't
seen that in the Memphis Grizzlies for a
while and that's all it takes is one
game like this for guys to you know
start playing at that high level that's
that's the only thing they should be
focused on like we're not trying we're
not talking about Championship right now
let's just give a
self a chance let's just get to that
10th ninth or eighth spot and I think
you know he's good enough to you know
help his team do that can you ask sha a
question yeah do we have time um can he
ask you a question sure you're you're
you're your your rookie year when you
didn't make the playoffs right the first
year right when that number hit in
saying that you guys wasn't going to
make
it was there a deflation in your effort
and thinking and time in PR preparation
and honest was there honestly that we
didn't we didn't know to the last game
that we were not going to make it so we
cuz we were up and down and then one
game like we needed to win a game before
so you were closer I've been on teams
I'm saying that because I've been on
teams when we're like 15 games out oh no
we were and we were like okay we're out
without we're out of
contention you can noticeably see the
deflation in the room no we were game G
guys come guys who used to come at let's
say the games at 7:30 and they come at
5:30 to shoot now they're coming at 550
you know there you know guys who would
stay after and be in the Ice T for 20
minutes now they're in there for 15
minutes like everything shortens that is
a natural human I don't care if you're
in the NBA you're making millions of
dollars that is a natural instinct of
human nature so John Morant just killed
the human nature of we don't have a
chance anymore we're back and we have a
chance it's going to it's going to be a
scene on Thursday night they uh back
home in Memphis taking on the Indiana
Pacers in the first uh home game for
johar after the suspension after the 115
to3 win everybody on the
set am Shrek that was a little bit of an
exaggeration this was not this
was do you feel much more much on
okay when he walked up he faked it he
was faking out d
I oh man he
Wasing